[Musique]
après s'être débarrassé de Benito
Mussolini Rome va vivre 9 longs mois
occupés par les nazis avant d'être enfin
libérée par les forces alliées c'est
cette période trouble violente et
souvent méconnue de l'histoire italienne
que vient donc de nous raconter ce
documentaire réalisé par un affranchez
qu'elle a et nous allons maintenant en
débat plus au-delà avec nos invités
présents aujourd'hui sur ce plateau de
débat doc avec vous pour commencer
Marianne Mata Bonucci bienvenue vous
êtes historienne professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université Paris 8 et
membre de l'Institut universitaire de
France votre dernière ouvrage s'intitule
Le totalitalisme fasciste publié chez
CNRS édition et puis également avec nous
Frédéric lemoal pour bienvenue vous êtes
historien spécialiste du fascisme et
professeur au Lycée Militaire de
Saint-Cyr et votre dernier livre
s'intitule lui les hommes de Mussolini
il est à découvrir aux éditions Perrin
nous l'avons vu ensemble ce documentaire
10 juillet 1943 c'est le débarquement
des forces alliées en Sicile et puis 15
jours plus tard 15 jours plus tard le 25
juillet 1943 c'est la destitution de
Mussolini il est remplacé par Petro
Badoglio ça doit être la stupeur à Rome
on rappelle que Benito Mussolini est au
pouvoir depuis 1922 dans quel état
d'esprit sont les Romains ce fameux jour
de juillet 43 ou Benito Mussolini est
chassé du pouvoir et bien il y a donc un
communiqué du gouvernement qui annonce
effectivement que
Mussolini à la demande du roi remis sa
démission donc et le roi confie le
gouvernement à Pietro Badoo alors Pietro
Bado lui on n'est pas exactement un
homme neuf puisqu'il a occupé de haute
responsabilités sous le fascisme en
particulier il a été vice roi d'Éthiopie
donc ça marque à parfois
discontinuité effectivement puisque ce
n'est plus une seule ligne qui est aux
commandes mais sans rompre quand même
totalement avec ce qui précède et
d'ailleurs donc effectivement badollio
devient premier ministre et dans un
premier temps on fait savoir que
l'Italie reste au côté de laxe et ce
n'est que plus tard que effectivement
l'Italie va changer d'alliance alors le
la nouvelle est accueilli avec un
certain enthousiasme et même rapidement
avec euphorie c'est une forme de
première libération effectivement
qui va susciter des déceptions parce que
badollio justement s'inscrit quand même
dans une forme de continuité il ne va
pas abolir par exemple les lois raciales
comme une seule ligne aléadopter mais la
discussion
la discontinuité majeure et bien ce sera
la signature de l'armist avec les alliés
et ensuite le retournement d'alliance ce
fameux retournement d'alliance j'imagine
que dans la population italienne les
choses n'étaient peut-être pas aussi
clair que ça non plus à l'époque
Badoglio s'est dit dans ce documentaire
essaye de négocier
avec la vieilliée une porte de sortie
c'est peut-être ce qui va faire que les
Allemands vont décider d'occuper le
centre et le nord de l'Italie quelques
jours plus tard en fait ce que le projet
du roi Victor manuel 3 qui est
absolument central dans toute cette
histoire parce que c'est lui qui
destitue ce midi il ne faut jamais faut
jamais l'oublier qu'il le fait qu'il le
fait arrêter c'était une transition en
effet en douceur et en ce qui concerne
l'alliance avec l'Allemagne victoire
manuel 3 avait très peur de la réaction
des Allemands donc contrairement à ce
que voulait certains hiérarque fasciste
comme dit nos grands dit qui lui pensait
un retournement d'alliance immédiat le
roi lui opte pour une stratégie qui
correspond à son caractère c'est à dire
très prudente on continue à dire aux
Allemands que la guerre poursuivie à
leur côté les allemands n'en croient
absolument aucun mot et en même temps
secrètement des contacts sont pris avec
les alliés afin de négocier une sortie
de l'alliance avec allemande et la
signature d'un armistice alors que les
alliés avec bien prévenu que il
n'accepterait aucune négociation et que
il n'obtiendrait des forces de l'Axe
qu'une capitulation sans sans condition
donc la voix est absolument très étroite
pour le roi dans une situation
absolument infernale où vous avez les
d'autant plus que les forces alliées
piétinent pour le voir
alliés qui sont au sud et les Allemands
qui depuis plusieurs mois en fait parce
qu'il se doutait que quelque chose se
tramet envoyer des divisions en Italie
en théorie pour
protéger l'Italie d'une invasion alliée
mais qui en réalité devait servir aussi
à s'emparer du pays c'est ce qui va se
passer effectivement en septembre les
Allemands vont décider de libérer Benito
mussoliques qui est emprisonné sous
bonne garde et avec la garantie du
nouveau gouvernement italien on imagine
extrait du documentaire on en parle
juste après
[Musique]
Benito Mussolini au moment de cette
attaque du commando allemand qui va
libérer se trouve dans les Abruzzes à
2000 mètres d'altitude du côté italien
les Allemands décident de prendre les
choses en main si on comprend bien à ce
qui nous est dit dans ce documentaire et
ce qui a été cette histoire en replaçant
Mussolini à la tête d'une république
fantoche c'est le mot souvent utilisé la
République de Salou quelle était
l'intérêt des Allemands à ce moment-là
celle libération Mussolini et la mise en
place de cette fameuse République de
Salou il est toujours plus simple de
gouverner et d'ordonner par procuration
et donc les Allemands Hitler en
l'occurrence se dit que il faut
conserver un gouvernement qui aura une
forme de légitimité et une voix guère
qui d'autre que Mussolini pour placer à
sa tête ensuite il y a un réel lien
entre les deux dictateurs qui s'est
consolidé au fil des années et donc mon
meilleur ami a disait Hitler de
Mussolini absolument et il faut pas
oublier que Hitler c'est aussi construit
en regardant du côté de l'Italie
fasciste avec une grande admiration pour
Mussolini alors après cette libération
donc qui survient le 12 septembre
Mussolini qui est tout à fait
rocambolaise
Mussolini donc et ramené en Allemagne et
c'est de Munich qu'il va annoncer donc
la création de la République sociale
italienne République c'est important
parce qu'ils donc il annonce qu'ils rond
avec la monarchie alors que jusque là le
fascisme avait gouverné donc avec la
monarchie et il entend revenir aux
origines à la source du fascisme du
fascisme donc des années 20 sauf que
Benito Mussolini n'est plus que l'on
côte de lui-même dans la nuit du 11 au
12 septembre il tente de mettre fin à
ses jours c'est ce que j'ai lu en
tentant de se tailler les veines par
exemple
et Hitler ne lui laisse guère le choix
hors quelques avant Mussolini disait non
moi si c'est pour être l'autorité des
Allemands ce sera hors de question c'est
c'est pas possible or c'est ce qui va
bel et bien se passer c'est un homme qui
est
usé
malade au départ il ne voulait pas hein
revenir aux affaires et il a été Hitler
lui en quelque sorte effectivement
forcer la main indéniablement
l'Italie connaître le sort de la Pologne
absolument pas beaucoup jouer et donc il
arrive dans des conditions qui sont les
pires qui soient avec toute une partie
donc de la péninsule qui est désormais
occupée par la l'armée allemande une
zone dans le nord-est du pays qui est
littéralement annexé qui comme un peu
comme le nord-est de la France si vous
voulez et donc il arrive avec des
pouvoirs qui sont effectivement des
pouvoirs tout à fait limités mais il y a
quand même la volonté d'essayer d'avoir
une forme de
autonomie en par exemple en prétendant
restaurer le corporatisme enfin rénover
le corporatisme en essayant de revenir
aux sources aux origines
oui tout à fait le fascisme de la
République de Saint-Lô c'est
se veut débarrasser de tous les
compromis que Mussolini a dû faire pour
prendre le pouvoir 1922 les compromis
avec la monarchie bien évidemment donc
on revient effectivement un fascisme
vraiment très très purement républicain
les compromis avec les grandes
entreprises le grand capital les
compromis avec avec l'église du coup il
s'est coupé de soutien extrêmement
important ce qui ne veut pas dire qui
est pas une partie des Italiens qui
n'est pas soutenue la République sociale
italienne aussi incroyable que nous ça
puisse nous paraître aujourd'hui il y a
des millions d'Italiens qui se sont
engagés en faveur de cette république
malgré la violence et les horreurs qui
ont été réalisées à cette époque et la
décision de Mussolini d'accepter le
pouvoir est absolument fondamental dans
l'histoire de l'Italie parce que en plus
plus de la guerre étrangère c'est à dire
entre l'Allemagne et les Alliés c'est
ajouter une guerre civile entre ceux qui
soutenaient le fascisme républicain et
tous les mouvements antifascistes donc
ça a plongé l'Italie dans une situation
absolument terrible de guerre étrangère
et de guerre civile particulièrement
atroce ou les Italiens se sont entrés le
terme de guerre civile vous êtes
d'accord avec ça oui je dois dire que
c'est accepté maintenant depuis qu'un
grand historien qui s'appelait Claudio
Pavone et consacré un livre au sujet et
on peut véritablement parler de guerre
civile alors ça concerne le centre et le
nord de la péninsule parce que vous avez
des bons bien évidemment il y a les
Allemands qui sont là mais vous avez
aussi les Italiens qui s'affrontent avec
d'un côté ceux qui vont rejoindre la
résistance alors une résistance qui est
dominée par le Parti communiste avec les
groupes d'action partisanes mais où il y
a aussi d'autres forces les gens qui
viennent d'une formation
socialiste libérale on va dire qui était
le parti d'axe qui va devenir le parti
d'action qui était joystitia et Liberta
une partie aussi de cette résistance et
socialiste il y a aussi des forces qui
sont proches de la démocratie chrétienne
et en face vous avez en effet des
groupes qui sont des groupes
paramilitaires ou même une armée
officielle qui a été recrée par la
République sociale italienne mais par
exemple il y a une ministre qui est
affiliée aux nouveaux partis fasciste
républicains et donc ces gens vont en
effet s'affronter alors c'est vrai que
ça peut sembler étonnant mais il ne faut
pas oublier que le régime fasciste a
duré 20 ans qu'il y a toute une partie
de la jeunesse qui a été effectivement
à qui on a lavé le cerveau véritablement
la propagande joue un rôle très
important sous le régime fasciste et qui
du coup fidélité aux valeurs qui leur
ont été inculquées considèrent qu'il est
normal certains vont même rej rejoindre
le nord de l'Italie pour combattre donc
aux côtés de la République sociale
italienne alors parmi les le au sein du
gouvernement il y a peu il y a toute une
partie des hommes de Mussolini qui ont
effectivement quitté le navire mais il
reste quand même quelques fidèles qui
sont les plus extrémistes les plus durs
pendant ce temps-là à Rome le 6
septembre 1943 les nazis font leur
entrée dans la ville et très vite très
vite mettre en place des rafles
concernant la population juive romaine
extrait
mais il doit être chez guantana va
passer on avait une nouvelle stade
les collèges
[Musique]
alors dès le 16 septembre 43 un premier
convoi est acheminé Auschwitz il y a
cette fameuse rafle qui a lieu à Rome ou
1022 habitants du ghetto de Rome sont
envoyés aussi à Auschwitz 90% d'entre
perron dès leur sortie du train à Office
birkenhow et au total ce sont quelques
7000 13 arrestations qui auront été
opérées en Italie concernant la
population juive ce chiffre est tiré de
votre livre voilà les nazis mettent en
place la joie en Italie oui parce que
jusqu'à cette date Mussolini refusait de
livrer les Juifs italiens
y compris les Juifs dans les Balkans qui
étaient dans des zones occupées par
l'armée italienne ils étaient plutôt
protecteurs vis-à-vis de la population
juive dans les territoires qu'ils
occupaient eux tout à fait puisque
depuis fin 41 donc la décision a été
prise donc du du génocide et les nazis
se heurtent à une fin de non-recevoir de
Mussolini alors pas pour des raisons
humanistes qu'on pourrait imaginer
évidemment sur ce Mussolini pour des
raisons sans doute d'indépendance à
d'affirmer une certaine indépendance par
rapport à l'Allemagne ne pas faire
apparaître l'Italie comme une sorte de
de marionnette de Valais des nazis
l'opposition des militaires qui était
extrêmement forte de des officiers de
l'état-majeur qui refusaient de livrer
de livrer les Juifs et même en France
après l'invasion de la zone sud en 42
bah beaucoup de juifs français vont se
réfugier dans la zone d'occupation
italienne dans le sud-est de la France
donc il y a eu cette heure de de
protection
qui n'a pas empêché l'armée italienne de
commettre des atrocités dans les Balkans
mais les choses sont effectivement très
très complexes mais par contre quand le
régime s'écroule et bien la protection
que le régime fasciste assurait aux
Juifs italiens et bien s'écroule avec
avec elle et du coup et bien ils sont
livrés à la maladie des nazis dans le
centre et surtout dans dans le Nord dans
le Nord où se trouve la République de
Salo autrement dit la République de Salo
a largement contribué à
la population juive italienne il faut
différencier l'attitude dans les
territoires occupés par l'Italie où il y
a cette forme de schizophrénie qu'on
évoquait pour des raisons géopolitiques
et politiques là l'Italie refuse de
déporter les Juifs et ce qui se passe en
Italie même où je rappelle quand même
qu'entre 38 donc et 43 il y a eu des
lois dures qui sont tout à fait
comparables à celle du régime de Vichy
qui ont été adoptés et appliqués
lorsque est proclamé la République
sociale italienne les Juifs sont
considérés comme appartenant à une
nationalité ennemie c'est dit dans un
texte officiel et très vite dès novembre
43 effectivement les procédures de
déportation sont mises en oeuvre alors
la rafle du ghetto les Allemands se
méfient et il n'y a que la police
allemande qui participe aux arrestations
mais ensuite il va y avoir une
collaboration entre les Allemands et les
Italiens et la police italienne va
largement contribuer les autorités les
institutions à la déportation donc des
Juifs d'Italie et le gouvernement
italien s'est très bien ce qui se passe
dans l'Est de l'Europe donc c'est une
certaine façon si vous voulez la
confirmation que ce n'est pas pour des
raisons humanitaires mais bien pour des
raisons de real politique au fond que
Mussolini protégeait avec 1000
guillemets les Juifs dans la zone
d'occupation
très peu de Juifs reviendront d'ailleurs
pour ceux qui ont été déportés
reviendront de déportation du côté
italien absolument absolument
ne pas évoquer plus doux cette évoqué
dans cet extrait que nous venons de
passer ça a été effectivement et
forcément évoqué dans le documentaire
que nous avons vu ensemble pourquoi
c'est assourdissant silence de depuis 12
alors que cette rafle a lieu quasiment
sous ses fenêtres au Vatican à Rome
alors il y a l'aspect global il y a
l'aspect local si vous permettez
l'aspect global c'est effectivement sa
stratégie qui est celle du silence ne
pas protester parce qu'il est persuadé à
tort ou à raison mais il est persuadé
que une protestation publique entraîne
plus de conséquences négatives sur les
victimes et sur ceux qui protègent les
victimes donc il vaut mieux se taire et
faire une action souterraine et c'est là
où on arrive à la stratégie locale
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement il n'a il
y a pas eu de protestation publique au
moment des rafles du 16 octobre mais il
y a eu une action souterraine il y a eu
trois actions une première auprès de
façade d'Allemagne ou le secrétaire
d'État c'est-à-dire le numéro 2 du
Vatican menace le Reich d'une
protestation de la part du du pape si
les rafles continuent et il y a eu deux
actions auprès du haut commandement
allemand qui est dirigé par le général
tarel qui d'ailleurs lui-même lui-même
catholique à travers deux personnages
dont l'un est le neveu du pape car le
patchelli pour faire pression pour que
les rafles s'arrêtent et effectivement
les rafles il y a eu la première RAF du
du 16 octobre et il n'a pas eu il n'a
pas eu d'autres c'est à dire que
des arguments militaires ont été
soulevés par le haut commandement
allemand disant qu'on avait besoin des
troupes pour aller combattre les Alliés
plutôt que de les consacrer au
déportation et donc on ne peut pas dire
que P12 n'est rien fait ce n'est pas
vrai en tout cas néanmoins son silence a
surpris les Allemands eux-mêmes puisque
cette race a eu lieu le 16 octobre
1943 le 28 octobre auprès du Saint Siège
écrit avec soulagement et satisfaction
je le cite le pape bien que sollicité de
diverses parts n'a pris aucune position
publique contre la déportation des Juifs
de Rome
si vous voulez lui son objectif qui
lui-même un conservateur lui son
objectif c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de
rupture entre le Saint Siège et
l'Allemagne donc il a passé son temps
dans ses dans ses dépêches à édulcorer
la position du pape et les menaces du
pape parce que lui effectivement il ne
veut pas de rupture donc lui
effectivement il sent il s'en félicite
le principal c'est que les personnes et
étaient effectivement sauvées dans les
institutions religieuses comme le montre
très bien le documentaire et évidemment
en pleine connaissance depuis 12 alors
là j'apporterai peut-être un point de
vue un petit peu différent
d'honorable après la guerre non plus oui
je veux dire la l'irra la rafle à Rome
s'arrête à ce moment-là mais il y a
d'autres rafles menés dans les
conditions que j'évoquais en
collaboration avec les polices qui vont
avoir lieu dans d'autres points d'Italie
et cela jusque très tard y compris à
Rome des attestations continueront
ensuite simplement il n'y aura plus de
rafles massives parce que pour toute une
série de raisons ça apparaît comme étant
plus compliqué à mener y compris
vis-à-vis de l'opinion en attendant les
juifs qui ont été à rester le millier de
juifs qui a été arrêté il part à
Auschwitz et ils vont être gazés donc là
l'intervention de la papauté et quand
même toute relative dans ses effets
ensuite
l'opération italienne n'a pas compris ce
silence depuis 12 à l'époque
au même moment Rome a été bombardé
d'ailleurs le documentaire le montre
très bien et là le pape s'engage il va
auprès de la population
il aurait pu descendre quand les Juifs
sont amassés près du théâtre Marcellus
et ailleurs on ne le voit pas à ce
moment-là donc il y a quand même si vous
voulez une attitude c'est un pape qui
d'ailleurs après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale va également faire entendre sa
voix contre le communisme donc il y a
quand même une forme de silence alors il
y a différentes façons de l'expliquer
moi je si on se réfère à un historien
qui s'appelle Giovanni colis
il y a peut-être une tradition longue
d'antisémitisme d'antig judaïsme qui est
un peu à l'oeuvre et qui considère que
finalement il faut se résigner à
certaines formes de persécution dans les
Juifs sont victimes parce qu'en revanche
effectivement alors les institutions
religieuses le documentaire le montre
très bien aussi vont jouer un rôle très
important en accueillant
les juifs ou combien certains prêtres se
sera le cas de Don Morosini qui est le
héros du film de rosselly ni paieront de
leur vie ces têtes qu'ils ont apporté
aux Juifs comme d'ailleurs aux
résistants etc
c'est indéniable mais après la guerre
dans les mêmes couvent passeront aussi
des fascistes des nazis
filières vaticales
il y a une tradition de charité
d'assistance qui est je dirais dans la
loi catholique dans la récapitulaire
est sorti dans Rome au moment des
bombardements mais attention il est
sorti en juillet et en août du moment où
les Allemands entrent
occuperont en septembre la ville est
encore bombardée il n'est jamais sorti
il n'est plus jamais sorti du moment où
les Allemands occuperont ils ne sort
plus ni pour les Romains ni pour les
Juifs ni pour qui que ce soit il ne
change plus ensuite sur le poids
antisémitisme les documents ne nous
montrent pas passe là il n'y a vous
pensez bien que si on avait trouvé un
document qui prouverait chez pidous un
sentiment antisémite ou même anti
judaïque qui pourrait expliquer que il
n'est rien fait il n'a rien dit je suis
d'accord mais c'est un fait mais dire
qu'il l'a il n'a rien fait ça ça c'est
absolument faux et vous parliez du
sentiment des Romains alors il va
falloir m'expliquer pourquoi dès la
libération de Rome les Juifs romains
sont allés au Vatican remerciés le pape
de ce qu'il avait fait si vous voulez au
sommet de la filière de de secours dans
Rome occupé on a Monseigneur mon tini
sur Montigny c'est futur Paul VI va en
faire en représentant de la droite la
plus la plus ultra alors c'est lui qui
chapote tout ça c'est lui qui met des
faux écriteaux sur les bâtiments de Rome
en disant ces propriétés du Saint-Siège
alors que c'est pas profiter du
Saint-Siège et il y a beaucoup de
réfugiés à l'intérieur on peut pas
imaginer une seule seconde que Montigny
et agit sans à référer au pape tous les
chefs tous les les religieux les AB et
les abaisses qui ont accueilli des juifs
comme le montrait bien le documentaire
ont tous expliqué après la guerre que
bien sûr ils agissaient en conformité
avec ce que voulait le pape ça peut pas
être autrement quand on sait que le pape
est l'évêque du diocèse de Rome on est
en train d'engager un débat sur Pidou
pourquoi pas mais il n'y a aucun
document jusqu'ici qui montre que le
Pape a donné une consigne au clergé aux
responsables pour accueillir les Juifs
il n'y a pas eu de consignes officielle
qui a donné donc s'ils l'ont fait
c'était que l'on sache de leur propre
initiative le pape était sans doute
informé mais il n'y a pas eu de
sauvetage orchestré organisé par le
Vatican jusqu'ici en tout cas peut-être
que les archives montreront autre chose
mais pour le moment ce n'est pas le cas
j'arrive le montreront pas parce qu'il
ne peut pas y avoir d'ordre écrit dans
une ville qui peut parler allemand donc
forcément des ordres ont effectivement
remercier le Vatican et l'église parce
que l'église est une institution
pyramidale hiérarchique et qu'il
s'imaginait probablement que c'était une
action coordonnée mais pour le moment on
en a aucune preuve on va voir un
troisième extrait et cette fois c'est
l'arrivée des Américains dans Rome nous
sommes le 5 juin 1944
les Allemands ont évacué Rome un
opérateur à plus d'une fenêtre filmé la
retraite des derniers éléments de la
wehrma
les troupes aliés n'étaient pas loin et
l'ennemi ne semblait pas tenir à être
rattrapé ainsi ça cheval règne de Hitler
sur la ville éternelle
parce qu'on pourrait appeler la deuxième
libération de Rome mais cette fois c'est
la bonne 5 juin 1944 d'ailleurs cette
libération passe un tout petit peu
inaperçu aux yeux de l'histoire
aujourd'hui parce que le lendemain c'est
le débarquement mais cette fois du côté
de la Normandie néanmoins en Italie
j'imagine que c'est une date qui reste
dans toutes les mémoires mais les
Italiens avaient pas pour autant
complètement fini avec Benito Mussolini
oui c'est à dire c'est un soulagement
pour les Romains en effet mais je
rappelle que la guerre va durer jusqu'en
avril donc 1945 nous sommes en juin
1944 donc la situation va rester très
difficile en effet jusque là bien sûr
alors justement comment est-elle cette
situation politique italienne entre
5 juin 44 et je suis la mort de Benito
Mussolini qui interviendra le 28 avril
1945 en fait la progression des armées
alliées a été extrêmement lente ils ont
débarqué en juillet 43 ils arrivent dans
le Nord en avril 45 la péninsule
italienne et le la géographie physique
de la péninsule italienne favorisait
évidemment la défense les Allemands ont
installé des deux lignes de défense
successives qui barraient la route aux
Alliés en plus du débarquement Sicile
les Alliés ont fait quand même deux
autres débarquements à Salernes et en
duo au sud de Rome donc c'était une
progression extrêmement lente
extrêmement meurtrière ce qui a d'abord
d'ailleurs convaincu les Américains de
d'abandonner les stratégies
périphériques chers à Churchill et de
l'a engager un débarquement en Normandie
c'est à dire frapper là où l'ennemi et
le plus fort parce que il ne parvenait
pas à
mais la guerre civile que vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure
est achevée se termine après cette
fameuse libération de Rome
se poursuit elle se poursuit elle se
poursuit jusqu'au bout et les les
Italiens ont été extrêmement extrêmement
puissants et d'ailleurs je pense que ça
aura une conséquence plus tard au moment
du référendum de sur la monarchie en
1946 parce que c'est vraiment les
provinces du Nord qui ont massivement
voté pour la République parce que c'est
là où vraiment les aurores fascistes
avaient été les plus terribles et
l'occupation la plus la plus longue il y
a donc eu de la part du nord de l'Italie
un rejet de la monarchie qui avait été
associé bien sûr au fascisme alors que
et c'est là elle paradoxe de l'histoire
le sud de l'Italie a resté est resté
quand même très fidèle au Savoie donc ça
a eu une conséquence voilà sur même la
forme institutionnelle du régime à la
fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
puis l'Italie contemporaine en fait
c'est construite sur l'héritage de
l'antifascisme sur l'héritage de la
résistance les institutions même
politiques italiennes ont été pensées
pour empêcher tout retour à un régime
autoritaire institution tel qu'on les
connaît encore aujourd'hui
la fin de Mussolini obscure il est tué
donc par les partisans et ensuite son
corps son corps est exposé au public
pendu la tête en bas avec sa maîtresse
oui et d'autres hiéracles la fin dans
l'histoire italienne dans cette histoire
dont nous parlons aujourd'hui c'est à
l'image de ce qui a été l'histoire de
cette république social italienne qui a
renoué avec les origines du fascisme
dans ce qui est licence même du fascisme
c'est à dire la violence parce que ça a
été un régime d'une violence absolument
inouïe le documentaire en parle aussi il
ne faut pas oublier qu'il y a eu des
massacres de civils qui ont été
perpétrées les questions des fausses
ardeatines qui est un moment quand même
absolument terrible puisque dans la vie
35 victimes fusillés les Allemands
prenaient un état d'isotage pour un
Allemand tuer à l'occasion tuer les uns
sur les autres au bout d'un moment ça
rappelle les massacres design Groupon
sur le front de l'Est et il va y avoir
autour de 25000 victimes de massacres de
ce type là en Italie non d'ailleurs une
partie son perpétrées par des Italiens
donc autour de 20% à peu près donc ça
donne quand même une idée du climat donc
dans lequel les choses se terminent et
l'exposition du corps de Mussolini des
hiérards et de sa maîtresse c'est une
réponse en fait à ce qui avait été fait
quelques mois plus tôt sur le lieu même
ou des résistants après avoir été
exécutés avaient été exposé leur cadavre
avait été exposé sur la même place et
c'est très symbolique parce que
Mussolini avait fini par incarner à lui
tout seul le fascisme parce qu'en fait
il y a eu plusieurs
des années 50 il y a pratiquement plus
aucun fasciste dans les prisons
italiennes est-ce que l'Italie aurait
oublié cette douloureuse histoire que
nous avons évoqué ensemble au point
délire une néopasciste à sa tête
aujourd'hui c'est pas néo fasciste il a
eu un dans sa genèse un engagement qu'on
peut approche mais bien sûr de Georgia
le rapport au passé est très complexe et
c'est rien à voir avec l'Allemagne de
rapport avec la mémoire n'a rien avec
l'Allemagne parce que il y a encore une
partie des Italiens effectivement qui
considèrent que finalement ce régime
était pas si mauvais que Mussolini a
réalisé deux bonnes choses pour pour
l'Italie qu'il a commis des erreurs en
politique étrangère notamment à
l'alliance avec l'Allemagne l'entrée en
guerre c'est certain mais il n'y a pas
une un rejet absolu total dans
l'ensemble de la population italienne
vis-à-vis de de ce régime
bon ça s'explique tout en fait
historiquement parce qu'il y a pas eu le
processus de mémoire comment comme en
Allemagne parce que aussi le régime
aussi violent a-t-il été n'a pas atteint
le degré d'horreur du Troisième Reich ou
de l'URSS donc ça ça rend le rapport
avec la mémoire un peu plus un peu plus
complexe et il faut quand même rappeler
que la famille Mussolini a toujours vécu
tranquillement en Italie qu'il est
lui-même enterré tout à fait
tranquillement si j'ose dire en Italie
donc le rapport à la mémoire est très
très complexe et qu'on lui rend hommage
à chaque fois qu'il est question de
célébrer l'anniversaire de de sa mort
merci un grand merci à tous les deux
d'avoir participé à cette émission j'ai
omis de préciser aussi qu'à Rome devrait
voir
bientôt naître un musée consacré à la
Shoah en Italie ça a été annoncé par
l'actuel gouvernement italien vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des Badoc
sur Twitter bien entendu merci aussi à
sel massali qui comme à la coutumée m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission je vous
donne tout simplement rendez-vous pour
un prochain débat doc et bien sûr avec
son documentaire et son débat à très
bientôt
[Musique]